Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers,
this is "Late Night."
Hope you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
I'm gonna get to the news.
After teasing
a "major announcement"
on his social media
platform Truth Social,
former President Trump
announced today
he is releasing a collection of
digital trading cards.
It's what his doctors are
calling "a new symptom."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
former President Trump
is releasing a collection
of digital trading cards
that chronicle his
life and career,
like that time he won
the Super Bowl,
or that time he won NASCAR,
or that time he went to
space and didn't need a helmet.
[ Laughter ]
I know, we always thought
he was Forrest Gump,
but apparently he does, too.
[ Laughter ]
First lady, Dr. Jill Biden
has reportedly grown
more enthusiastic
over the last three months
about the possibility
of President Biden
running for a second term.
Anything to put off her
having to deal with
a newly retired guy.
[ As Biden ] Get ready, babe,
because I'm about to
get into model trains
big-time!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The Biden
administration announced today
that U.S. households can now
order an additional
eight free at-home COVID tests.
It's the perfect gift for the
person who has everything but
isn't sure if it's the flu,
COVID, or RSV.
[ Laughter ]
The United Nations voted
yesterday to remove Iran
from a panel which promotes
women's rights,
which is kind of like
Arby's being stripped
of its Michelin star.
[ Laughter ]
I think they still have one,
because I think they got
two Michelin stars.
Goldman Sachs is reportedly
considering cutting bonuses
this year for
investment bankers.
As for how they're cutting it --
with baking powder!
All right.
[ Laughter ]
It's not fair to say
all finance guys do cocaine,
just the winners!
[ Laughter ]
Producers yesterday released a
trailer for a new reality series
called "MILF MANOR."
[ Laughter ]
"MILF MANOR?"
You mean Williams-Sonoma?
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that what that's called?
I'm genuinely asking.
And finally, a deer in India
recently got stuck
in an ATM vestibule.
But good luck trying to get
just one buck
out of an ATM.
[ Scattered laughter ]
And that -- and that was how
Brian Donaldson
ruined Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, that was the
monologue, everybody!